[Music]
I'm very excited to be a very excited
sometimes he can understand sometimes
comedians say that and we don't
necessarily mean it like I was playing a
club recently on the outskirts of Toledo
Ohio alright and at one point I don't
know why but I yell out to the crowd I'm
like I'm excited to be here in Toledo
some woman up front leans over and yells
out technically you're in Perrysburg I
go technically I'm not excited to be
here we're all just exchanging
pleasantries women are intense man even
my wife we got stuck in a hotel elevator
recently for like ten minutes okay my
wife looks over at me right she's like
check the ceiling hatch I go what she
goes check the ceiling hatch see if it's
unlocked
I go why so Bruce Willis has a way to
get down here and say I'm like what if
it is on lock you really think I'm gonna
climb out of the elevator shimmy up that
cable while I'm pry open the door to the
next level so we can get back on with
the mission that we must be offered I
thought we were go for coffee but
apparently we were on a secret mission
that I hadn't been debriefed on yet the
hotel gave us a bottle of champagne for
the inconvenience and I accidentally
spilled it all over the carpet and I
bring it up because the emotional
difference between spilling something in
your own home as opposed to spilling it
in a hotel room fascinating right but
you spill some in your own home right
away you like give me a rag hurry up
it's gonna stain you spill the same
thing in a hotel room you're like oh
don't step there you're wet you stop
it's good though now but I have a baby I
have a one one and a half year old baby
and it's good cuz it diverts my wife's
attention for once you know but I'm
gonna spring [ __ ] this kid came out of
nowhere
I gotta tell you my wife's no spring
chicken either even my best friend right
he comes out to me recently it's like
dude are you ready
17 years from now are you ready to be up
all night waiting for your daughter's
boyfriend to drop it back off I got 17
years from now I'm not even gonna be
awake when he picks her up know what
you're talking about bring him by in the
morning when daddy's going fishing I'll
meet him there
I don't really fish I don't really I
live in a small town now know where a
lot of men fish they're always talking
about the lake and how close it is and
I'm always like but I wouldn't fish if
there was a lake in my living room I
almost went fishing with a guy though
cuz I like eating fish who doesn't right
so I call him up we're gonna go fishing
the day before call up and I'm like what
are we fishing for anyway and he goes oh
it doesn't matter where we're going when
it's catch and release I almost drove
four hours to a lake to catch fish let
him off the hook and put him back in the
water
I'm like bro if that's fishing to you I
would rather just stay in the city and
go parking
it's like what do you mean I go no
that's when you drive around you look
for a spot then you pull in and then you
pull back out yeah yeah and after you
after you pull back out then you drive
around and look for another spot while
you discuss how exciting it was that you
just found that last five feet oh man I
need a hobby right even like my dad
loves golfing my brother loves golfing I
tried to watch recently the Ryder Cup
the international bets golf tournament
I'm like let me watch a little this I'll
call up my dad after like two holes
there's like my lids my eyelids are just
this weights on like just kids stay
awake so don't figure I better take a
nap I go on the other room I lay down
close the shades and now a wide awake
right I met that's when it dawned on me
golf played at its highest level is
still more boring than the dark
the only way to see it no one speaking
of sports though now raising this kid
it's a crazy time raising kids right
they're all equal no losses no losses I
went to my nieces literally game out in
Jersey right my niece is 8 years old now
her team was up ten three after two
innings my brother comes walking up to
the little bleachers right my brother
yells Isaac what's the score I'm just
about to tell him a mother on the other
team stands up and she goes ah the score
is having fun - having fun we don't keep
score at this age guys like god I look
at my brother I'm like yeah well so far
we had fun ten times
I made fun three times
[Applause]
you